all right for those joining the
livestream we are discussing a thorny
problem of how to handle missing data in
all sorts of often language situations
so the way this came up in part was even
in the data repository where data has
been somewhat cleaned we're still
dealing with situations in which some
data is missing and messy and I guess
the issue is what then happens with our
various functions okay so um Bret
maybe we can will let's talk about by
the way I hope somebody is dealing with
the thing for 11:3 okay
so let's let's make a list of what um
both how does data you know how is data
missing and then what should consume
missing data okay so for example how is
data missing well an example would be
it's actually missing of dot dot or it's
simply not in a desired format to Idina
miracle
since you see whether we can oh we
already had a discussion about missing
data I don't know how long ago let's we
should check what was there okay um okay
what surprisingly he said it's a thorny
issue yes well we've been looking at
this for four years right okay so what
should consume missing data so and you
know so one example would be graphics
functions another example would be
machine learning functions another
example would be statistics functions
another one would be data set and there
probably others okay so fundamentally
for graphics functions what action
should one take presumably the primary
action is don't plot it
do we agree or not that's the general
philosophy specifically plot what you
can and ignore the rest yes but now do
we give a message
currently no I mean pre version six we
did but it was one of those cases where
you got one message for every element
that wasn't yeah that's stupid
okay do we show a pool of missing stuff
right so there's some plot types where
there might be a pool of missing stuff
like for example we could imagine in a
histogram we could imagine that you know
you plot the main histogram and then you
have over on one side a gray bar
indicating all the stuff that couldn't
be plotted
that's an interesting idea and like
obviously histogram doesn't do that but
something like bar charts will leave
space where the data would have been
right okay so look so there's the main
action is don't plot it but other things
are you know another so what are the
possible actions one of us don't plot it
and you know do we leave space for it do
we indicate a lack of a lack of data so
let me give you an example so array plot
as I recall if I say array plot you know
1 0 0 1 1 foo
zero-one one has a lovely brick-red
where the food should be right so that's
an example of one where we where we do
show something which is right because if
we showed it as white we would be
confusing people right so similarly in a
surface so right so their various
actions eg you know in a surface we
could you know a interpolate across the
missing data
okay another thing we do another thing
we do for some of these messing data we
and we should set this up um another
thing we do we can use we could use a
dotted line unless line plots so that
happens for example if we did who knows
whether we can I mean in in Wolfram
Alpha right we do that if we were to if
we were to say
um you know something like
mr. owner you know if I were to say
temperature in Timbuktu
who knows how good the weather recording
stuff is at boo boo boo airport okay
right so just there's right there's a
gap
right you know so that's another another
modality I don't know what I sure it
sticks out for that do you know no I
don't know what their heuristic is for
that okay so walk me through some other
things we do so I mean another case in
in the case of bar chart if I go you
know one two three fou four I'll just
look like that it's arguably not the
right thing I mean arguably that should
indicate that that was a you know that
should do something more like this
perhaps yes so let's walk through okay I
mean so let's let's talk about cases
where it's just absolutely wrong so for
example let's say dateless plot yeah so
there we've got I don't know how to get
a good list of dates um you can just use
yesterday today tomorrow and whatever
okay they are usually once
right that's gonna be shown pretty much
nothing I think yeah that's so that's
obviously wrong right you know if you
had today for tomorrow foo then you
would get a section of the line
corresponding for you know that it could
draw that it has the two end points for
well that's just silly I mean that's
just silly I don't understand why that's
any different okay so let's let's look
at some different cases here okay it was
about that case when today what I think
when the date is me seen from my
memories it was a program as well right
that's the example that really triggered
this meeting okay so let's look at this
case list line plot of you know three
four five six foo two three four okay so
that just breaks the line there mm-hmm
now in the case where if I do something
like um what's a good example here if I
if I just say
something where there are a large number
let's say table no square root of I I
goes to 40 and then let's say replace
part
well now let's say 20 goes to foo
okay so that's what that's gonna look
like now arguably you know we're being
quite inconsistent in all these things i
mean arguably that would be better done
this way
that is when we know we're joining if
we're joining and there was data missing
there if we think we're doing a list
line plot we should be joining but
putting a dotted line there am I making
sense
um and I mean how would that relate to
some of our other ways of indicating
missing this I mean we have various
options for showing asymptotes and not
showing asymptotes and so on right now
so if we go back to array plot I think
it has is it documented okay I want to
say that it has an actual option that
controls the style of that red or maybe
it's just a method option that's not
documented but yeah I'm not seeing it so
so okay so in machine learning at the
end you've got some missing data some
functions that do things with missing
data right you've got some kind of
missing what do we call it right so
missing data rules missing data method
other things not really to us
Wow okay so we've got some existing
handlers
in particular missing data method
missing data rules missing data method
okay so what are these things missing
data rules is for semantic import
so that looks like a detection thing
yeah by the way um who's appearing here
is this Sushma here I don't think we
have any
we do not who would you want here I
think Sushma would be terrific let me
see if I can find her
I just will make sure that this goes in
the meeting that we have about data
cleaning functions because I have
forgotten about this um the heck is that
well okay so missing data rules is
basically specifying specifies
substitutions
for missing data and that's not I mean
arguably is it that or is it the other
way around that first their second
example looks like
I see specifies no no no I see specifies
okay so specifies which data should be
replaced by missing right so this is
like four formats where you have some
numbers it yeah right so that's the case
where so okay so missing data method
what does that do
you
okay so that's really what we're talking
about here things that things like
interpolation and so on right
so an example of that so that's that's
really what we want to deal with so like
for example what we would potentially
have potential formats potential objects
one would be a missing data style head
which in the case of something like this
could default to a dotted line right and
if you look at your you know question
missing star in the other notebook
there's actually a missing style which
is used by geo region value plot
I don't know why that didn't get you
know pushed back to rape lots sigh
that's why we're having a meeting like
this yep okay that's so bizarre that's
just totally weird okay so let's look at
okay then let's look at your region
value plots actually let's just do
missing style I'm sure we intended to do
that then in one example Oh
okay so first action item here would be
that um array plot should get a missing
style right which seems quite
straightforward right and there's
probably you know related things like
matrix plot and right okay let's let's
inventory more of these okay so list
line plots could have an automatic
missing style so what would we like okay
so let's back up just a little bit so I
think for the visualization functions we
have at least three cases that things
fall into right so one is where the
thing that's missing has a space for it
it has a space for it similar to array
plot okay so let's let's let's um
okay so what we've got here is types of
missingness types of missing lists in
visualization okay so one thing is um
there's a space there's a place to put
something but the data isn't there right
okay so examples of that include array
plot geo region value plot bar chart I
believe
a chart I believe - no not pie chart
okay so let's think about pie chart so
pie chart yes pie chart what happens if
I say pie chart of you know one one one
fou one you'll get quarters
I see I see okay so then okay right and
in the case of bar chart we know how
wide a bar is generally speaking right
right there's no place to put something
well there's no
there's no predefined space in other
words the value this is a case where the
value defines the amount of space right
okay so in other words this is a case
where something else defines the amount
of space defines the space the value is
just determining how it's colored as
determining eg how its colored right is
it okay
so that's one situation there okay the
second thing is there's no predefined
space to put something
yeah of which this is an example right
and and that's okay so another one is so
so basically I mean to some extent I
would separate bar chart out of that
first category okay well there's another
category here where where the the thing
that's missing was supposed to say where
something should go okay so that's in
the
a degree of that stateless plot with a
missing date for example
okay why would you separate bar chart
that means so in the case of array plot
and geo region value plot if the value
is missing but you but that's just a
styling for a region right that the
region is entirely defined whether or
not it the value is missing
all right there's a sub case here which
is in in inferred quotes x value cases
eg lists of values so that is the case
of bar chart right that's an inferred x
value well my point is and I'm not sure
whether this is capturing captured by
your inferred x value you know in the
case of array plot we know exactly how
big that you know square is that it
would go in in the case of bar chart we
know how wide it is but we have no
knowledge about the height right you
know so we have sort of half the space
dimension I search you're saying I
search a say I see what you're saying
okay so so this is actually a different
case you're right something else defines
the position but not what's rendered
there
but what's rendered there is missing
what should be rendered is missing okay
so the cases for that are bar chart one
to fou also lists plot one to fou I
claim there's another case like that
something else is defined as a tuples
case of loose loveless plot exactly
right but not list plot one to fool bar
alright right that's the next category
right there are no predefined you know
it's not actually actually let's let's
break the support because this category
no no and then we've got this that's
part of this category
actually I mean for the conceptual I
mean it is but rendering wise now yeah
then it's just gonna be missing and it
just isn't there right well or is it not
there I mean that we could have a tick
okay so let's consider that case um this
case okay here could have a tick a mark
on the x-axis that one could have a mark
on the x-axis right to indicate that
missing thing but this one is hopeless
right you know that one possibly you
know if we had some you know going back
to your concept of pools or something
yeah right we just have some collection
of great points off in the corner or
something that right but let's consider
this case here let's consider the case
this here that could have a tick on the
y-axis
okay so let's consider a list line plot
see okay there's no predefined space to
put something
you
okay that this is that's okay then
another case is there are things um
let's see
the missing spot could be quotes papered
over okay by which I mean list line plot
right right I have one two three four
five um let's see so then um what are
other examples where it could be papered
over so plot plot is another good
example where it could be paid but over
a plot square root of x x from minus 3
to 3 correct you know any of the surface
you know variance of these sorts of
things but don't they already have a
papering over mechanism not really plot
3d have a have a way of saying what to
do when it's missing
no it has a way of saying what to do if
it gets clear of the flight range gets
clipped you know automatically I see I
see I see right okay so it needs a
missing style as well and but of course
in general for the for the function
plotting stuff how does it do its
adaptation around the around the region
of trouble because it does it's adaptive
algorithm correctly mapped the region of
missingness it should do a decent job of
it because basically what it does is it
looks at you know here's a value it's
three over there is missing or none or
whatever all right so this these could
you know fix a point in between right
everything we've described could be
handled by a missing style the only
problem is in this papering over method
okay so these things need a missing
style but they also need a papering over
method they need a missing this one
needs okay so these need need missing
style and a missing data method a
missing method or something right
because they need to say whether it's
interpolation not what it is
right right so so examples of missing
data methods so here if we say missing
missing method missing data method
whatever and this is where the machine
learning folk might because what do you
have a TN and amia what what do you have
for missing because you have imputation
right you have missing imputation of
various kinds this will be so you're
talking internally or the top level
function will have well what do we do
what do we have in terms of options
right now do we have options for
missingness what do we do right now with
missing no there's no sense
what we do is so all machinery function
and all missing data we automatically
find a method so I mean there's some
some method that can handle missing data
and there's no problem
but it is cannot then there's a missing
imputation method that is selected
automatically and and basically for
numerical data we use dimension
reduction that can be learned with
missing data and then there's there's a
way to impute missing data using the
dimensional user that's what we do for
or for other data type like categorical
data and so on there's a nice computer
like you know select sampling from the
distribution of the categorical variable
or just taking the most common or things
like this it's not a good idea
I mean in other words it's better you
have you have you give them a she
learning you know feature vector I mean
you know bunch of features and you have
like 100 of them and one is missing are
you going to throw out the vector and if
you do that in will datasets we don't
have anything so that's why right fair
enough okay so so what you're doing then
you're missing method how do you have an
option to say how to do the imputation
or do you just go ahead and do the
imputation no no we just do it it's not
fun although as soon as we have the top
level function missing imputation there
will be some method and definitely I
think we should use this since there's
already a symbol missing that a method
probably we should use that to select
yes to give the user the control on what
method to use okay so missing data
method whatever it's called missing
method missing data method whatever
we're doing there my question would be
in the case of plot 3d okay
so these principle I mean you know
that's the question what should you do
in that missing style region I mean
probably in the case of plot 3d so I
would claim let's let's take a look at
the function produce me singing input 3d
yeah if the function produce is missing
right so I claim plot 3d missing style
should be none
by default other words just don't plot
it there that's the current behavior
right okay so in the case of lists line
plot I think there's a possible
that missing style should be dotted what
do you think I'm not opposed to that I'm
not sure how much work it would be to
hook up I mean but I can definitely sort
of see it you know general outline of
how we'd go about it yeah but it's
clearly useful to be able I mean
certainly that should be possible the
stylist started whether that should be
default I'm not sure I mean it's like
there isn't any data there so what do
you do I mean it's it's a question of
event series versus time series type
thing right I mean and this would help
well I mean like the list line plots get
even more interesting so so let's here's
an example for you to try mm-hmm okay
list line plot of 1 2 3
- four bar five six
you
how did that too right I mean so the
four got hung out to dry because nothing
on either side of it was renderable so
we don't get a line segment you can
review it it's a turn on plot markers
that would actually put it in that point
okay let's take a look well mesh arrow
true right
that seems like a bug train mesh goes to
all
oh I see that's right okay yeah that's
an interesting case okay so in the case
we're missing style
I see so what's tricky there in the case
we're missing style is dotted you have
to go through that point right I mean
but the question is do we have some way
of indicating that that point
is actually their sure thing
okay yeah you you're correct that if
look if you don't switch on mesh all you
see if it so happens that that point is
does not cause a break in the line if
you understand what I mean it's not
cause a break in the first you know in
the jump in the in the first derivative
type thing then yes you won't see it but
if it does cause you know if it does if
it is a a control point that actually
matters then you'll see it which i think
is okay right all right let's take a
look here for the sake of this
discussion hat okay so I mean an another
category of thing is you know all the
statistics functions and I don't think
we have a good representative here for
from those does anybody know how we're
handling that um what the
I mean we certainly have some missing
data rules for things like time series
but what about you think basic
descriptive statistics is probably just
falling back to you know symbolic sand
you probably get you know one third this
plus you know some fraction of missing
you know for a mean or something yeah
well that's just stupid
I mean statistics functions if we say
mean I mean unfortunately here we don't
have any special behavior for this I'm
pretty sure right you're gonna have a
missing in the yeah
but I don't know what the right answer
to that is either and what should that
be well I mean ends conceptually it may
be entirely different than if you
replace missing with X sure right so
that relates to what do you consider to
be missing right so that's you know ie
what do you consider to be missing this
is this a do you want Eric to see if you
can get Gosha sure yeah Kanishka
yeah I don't get the
Eric did you understand that is is it
right next word is suppose so
okay um okay
all right let's see so where were we
here so what is missing behavior what
was that it doesn't we looked at that
and I'm not familiar with it so oh my
gosh it's something really weird
that's funky that's truly funky so that
is what's relevant for things like mean
right so what's the default value
automatic I assume or yes I'm not
finding ghoshal okay
well that's kind of interesting what
that's doing I mean that's arguably that
should be an option in those various
functions
can any of those functions take options
that total probably can but it's a
little funky it's a little funky um but
what this is doing is it's providing an
outer wrapper for mean I mean this is
like a missing harness so to speak so I
mean that the concept there would be
what could we call it we could call it a
a missing harness for computations which
means something like
um I mean that the case here is
something like this right which is going
to give a stupid answer right now and it
will be something like
um
I don't think this is right the right
terminology but something like missing
blog no missing
well this again bad naming but missing
handler of mean of blah blah blah
that's kind of a stupid way to do it
that's an adverb it's kind of the adverb
mechanism which never goes well um it's
a question for Etienne or at least the
machine learning folk so the term impute
does that always mean replacing the
value or can it mean dropping it no it
means replacing right so in the case of
mean there is no replacement for missing
which will give the right answer
actually there is a replacement for
missing which will give the right answer
and that's nothing and by the way since
we allow having missing value in
machining functions we need to deal with
them all over the place to compute these
sort of things for example so I spent a
long time creating functions to you know
concrete means compute these and that
and work with missing but what do your
functions do I mean it's a process
saying sometimes you want to perform
processing on the data so simplest
example is standardize the data so you
need to compute the mean in some
obligation and so we also want to do it
fast right so you really checked if it's
a factorized into its normal way if it's
not packed it said that there's a
missing we move the missing continue the
computation yes
the same so I have some function
actually that I could propagate missing
so it's sort of a map but if it sees
missing then it still returned missing
okay in other words if it sees are
missing somewhere in the computation so
in this case instead of giving this
garbage your function would cause that
to return just missing so no no no
exactly I mean it's sort of a map so
it's something that is let's say a
function you want to map like f okay and
in say instead you do I don't know
map propagates missing okay map exactly
we'll be seeing an F and then you put
list yep and and if any of them is
missing it won't make f of missing it
will just return missing if any of the
ABC is missing oh I see I see I see one
of the function that I use remember
exactly the others but I had to have
these sort of utilities you know at
window losing
okay so basically what okay so hold on
so the F of one so what's interesting
about this I think there's a better way
to handle this okay so let's imagine
that the f itself was wrapped with
something that says if missing Q of slot
come a missing comma slot yeah well
that's what I meant but it basically I
mean let's write that out if missing Q
of thought then missing otherwise slot
well yeah yeah okay so what would that
be called what would that be that would
be a missing protected or missing
propagating
blah blah blah right yep and that with
the so that is a again it's an adverbial
type form but that's
that just means if it's
feda missing okay so this okay so let's
look here missing propagating what's the
right word um what is the right word if
if if the argument is missing the result
is missing well okay fine let's just say
missing handling of f missing handling
so then the semantics would be missing
handling of F of missing here goes to
missing but we can imagine something
where so the question is what happens in
this case here where it's a be missing
does that go to missing as well
I mean obviously you can give it a level
number the extended syntax of delete
missing
right but this is the inverse of this
behavior here in this behavior here you
are you know so there's really there's
really two things there's there's um
have missing pollute everything that's
case number one in case number two try
to ignore the missing try to compute
around the missing basically that right
I think so so I mean this is reminiscent
of in in numerix you know the NA n
construct would typically pollute things
for what it's worth right I mean that's
like indeterminate pollutes things right
I was just gonna point that one out
right so but none of this is related I
mean for the visualization functions
this isn't what's relevant for the
visualization functions I mean all of
this missing propagation stuff the
visualization functions they just take
what they have they're not going to
manage the data they're just looking and
seeing you know can I plus it or not I
think and that's a place where we need
to fix this okay so let's just take a
look at the route guide page and looking
at our visualization functions and just
remind ourselves what's there I'm sure
you know this much better than you know
every one of these we can ask what what
the deal is
the hum
it's um okay let me see um
3d pool yes I mean there's a question
wasn't earth do you do with that so
there you kind of have this membrane
you're literally papering it over it's
like you have a oh no you live a whole I
guess it actually depends on the case I
think you know if you have an array of
Heights it leaves a hole I think if you
have triples it currently pastes over
because the code is going in and doing a
de l'année triangulation of the existing
points and okay but does it use a
different style no that's bad probably I
don't know if it's bad I mean know that
list line plot I guess well this line
plot breaks the line right well or does
list line plot if if you have a if you
have something where you are going let's
say it's list line plot one two three
four fubar
five seven add one more point okay yes
so the plot range knows that it went out
to five seven you know even though that
didn't get drawn yeah by the way that's
another that's a complicated case right
a thing that's okay so this is an ugly
case so the missing spot could be
papered over and the sub case of that is
once the things around the missing are
gone once that the missing things
remove the plot ability of other points
you doubt that that's gonna not spell
correction any forms of other data eg so
that's eg a an isolated point in this
line plots hide or conceivably list plot
3d or whatever by the way we uh I'm I
was wondering if we're going to get some
comments from our livestream crew I see
one suggestion here related to a
different meeting which was some
discussion about Adam q Sushma I think
you were in the discussion about Adam q
so maybe you can the suggestion is to
name it partible q a see what I have to
say the word partible well while a quite
lovely word what an earth victim oh my
gosh
well that's interesting actually really
remember this it's a um this definition
yes I vaguely remember this a system an
inheritance in which a deceased person
the state is divided equally among their
heirs probably a good idea in general
saves arguments but I am ok actually
won't when we come back to the
discussion of Adam Q we could we can
have that yes um
but the people on the live stream can
think of other cases that we're not
thinking of please send something on the
chat ok let's take a look at some of
these other ones here timeline plot
you're basically just out of luck
you don't have a date well again let's
say that's a case where okay look things
missing was supposed to say where it
should go
okay so in this case time line plot
without a date again could imagine a
pool basically oh well okay someone is
going back here with this is a another
fail for our friends at Google let's see
what we say for the definition of
possible maybe they just picked up a bad
dictionary definition that's what you
get by just not actually having any
humans pay attention see whether we do
any better it was also possible that
your Google thing was just showing the
yeah they just got the wrong thing well
that's interesting okay well thank you
for that suggestion that's a much more
sensible I mean it's clear to almost
anybody what it means it's just humph
well that's a fail for don't don't trust
your search engine um I like that
actually good suggestion
so Sushma can you can you um I forget
which meeting the at McHugh discussion
resume was that an ILD meeting no in
which Michael Scott was said it was a
chemical-based meeting I wasn't there in
that but we had we had a discussion
later take a very brief discussion and
since that is where we will bring it
back okay we can send it to design
mm-hmm anyway I like that idea
good suggestion and actually it's a
that's a it's a good suggestion it's a
very clean suggestion because it does as
you say relate to the parts I like it
in fact I'm good
craft a piece of mail here so that I
remember okay
um okay let's go back over here for a
minute mine plot yeah I mean one could
imagine a a pool of lost events so to
speak you know what I'm saying that's a
case where just like we have a legend we
could imagine a pool you know in so far
as the timeline plots has you know the
Battle of such-and-such
of unknown date right you can just
imagine stacking them up somewhere and
you know having them obviously
disconnected from the timeline like at
the end of the timeline
they're almost wondering if you'd have
to like stick them off into a legend or
something to really make it obvious
what's going on yeah well not if you
break the axis how do you break the
timeline axis oh and my concern is that
if you put it anywhere along the axis
that people are going to read there
there's no but if you break the timeline
axis that is if those points are stacked
in other words if there's an axis and it
goes along and then the axis ends and
then these things are somewhere floating
away from the axis I think it is
somewhat clear right I mean the other
case that can happen with time line plot
is that I mean so so timeline plot can
do intervals and so then what happens
when you have only one end of the
interval is yeah then you're toast
missing and that actually you know ends
up being close to like the censoring
data in time series and whatnot and
statistics what is that
so the censoring is like when you're
doing like your testing hard drives
right oh right
you know that
you know every hard drive is gonna fail
eventually but we didn't wait long
enough to see all of them fail yes yes
okay eg and okay what are they date
intervals without an end right interval
with part of it missing okay so there's
another case here which is number line
plot for example
that's another ugly case right because
that's a case where we have the same
deal there is number line plot with
intervals with missing pieces it's just
very unclear what you do with that what
do we do right now
I imagine ik just throws out the entire
interval
unless it blows up completely but
hopefully not let's just see hmm that's
not good
so wouldn't be a bug I mean that the
pink is a bug but the you know
underlying primitives are actually not
awful but not awful well I mean we have
a point representing the end of that
interval that is that the right thing
though by the way that's Rob here I mean
that you know part of the reason I
wanted to I mean there's a bunch of QAS
who's here I mean have we been
systematically testing visualization
functions with with weird missing data
in them we must have done that for like
decades we do it in piecemeal I don't
have a systematic approach yet before
there are certain functions like this
plot of this line plot which have the
screws put to them pretty tightly there
are others like you found with a
histogram which don't that one was fun
which which one did I find I found eight
let's plot one that was issuing identity
messages istagram
yes that actually depended on the time
zone in some way whether the whether you
had dates that were in a time zone other
than what your dollar time zone was Wow
which is I think it's why we didn't
catch it
by the way Rob that that's an
interesting if I don't know who's doing
test development for date stuff but that
that thing just mentioned by Brett is an
interesting case which you should note I
found an interesting case myself also
with some of the tests were showing up
as you know they're producing on dates
that were a day later than I expected
because the internals were using GMT
time not are the local as far as missing
data is concerned it's got beds it's
more of a scattershot at virtual
deployment I do try to include
at least some missing data but we should
listen
listen we should you obviously have
templates for a bunch of these functions
we should make sure we run them with
missings in all the possible positions
in the templates and check for pinking
and all those kinds of things yes that
what you should do is just take take
meaningful tests take tests that are
reasonable and just have numbers in them
and just zap some of those numbers
that's another crazy thing that's what's
being doing that being done for let's
plot in this line I'm fine I'm just
seems like that should be extended but
right but listen the let's agree on the
principle we never generate a message
that our principle yes I think so right
do you agree at the end do you have an
opinion about that chemists okay so so
the question is if there is data that
cannot be plotted for some reason see I
actually okay so here's a case where I
think we should generate a message if
the thing is going to be empty
- plot yeah well we can return the empty
plot I don't have a problem with
returning the empty plot but I think
it'd be useful to issue a message saying
no data in this plot could be plotted
rather than just oops you generate an
empty plots I mean the other thing I
mean the other possibility is I don't
know how much work this would be would
be to have you know in the case that
there's missing data to issue one
message that says either how many
elements were missing or not plottable
or I think that's luxury I mean I think
that just saying there were no plottable
elements here is you know is really it's
kind of um it's kind of a good thing is
is asking for a message that's saying a
message would be nice for any missing
data especially if you automate lots of
plots being exported well that's an
interesting claim and I mean you know
another approach I mean we've only
tsunami Singh are we leaning toward a
mishandle not no no we're not we don't
we're not giving a message and I agreed
that so you know but but look so there's
a couple of different approaches we can
take so one thing that we're going to be
doing a lot more of is messages that are
off by default I think we're going to
have a whole framework for messages off
by default so this might be a way to
handle that is to have messages that are
there but off by default okay um the
alternative would be to make use of
something like a missing behavior um
that can you know it's your message or
not
think okay so this is a whole question
about okay so this is an interesting
idea that you have you know a missing
data method or whatever that you know
either in its entirety or a part of it
is complain you know issue the message
and um just a minute message is somebody
is husky on the live stream saying Siri
is missing a lot of data this is a
different sense of missing data this is
your data you are providing data and
some of the data you provide is missing
for some reason or another this is not
data about the world is being provided
and there's a question of whether we
have it all we make a big effort to have
it all and hopefully when things are
working properly Siri can get what we
have um there any case that okay so in
messages or not for missing data for
missing missing data and visualizations
elementary I have to run so any
questions please okay so the
possibilities are I think it is
important to give a message if there if
the thing is okay for interactive there
two cases there's interactive use
and there is non interactive use so to
speak and let's and by that I mean well
or interactive / and single plot type
use and there's no interactive or you
know scripted use so what do we mean by
that I mean in the case where we are
generating you know a table table of 200
plots right putting generating a message
somewhere which says boy it's making me
think that it would be better to have a
visual indication that there's missing
data in a plots because honestly in that
case I mean even pinking might not be
totally crazy I was gonna say that you
know that number line plot that Pink's
you know in some ways is you know a very
heavy now that's a very very heavy
version but but having some form of
pinking rather than just having I mean
that would be okay so let's consider the
case so let's say we say let's plot you
know ABC that's just gonna be a blanket
plot okay so how could we decorate that
blank plot in a way that is visually
obvious
and maybe has a mouse-over rather than
just oops there's nothing there we got
to indicate that it's an error because
the thing is that you know if you're
building something up right now so
you're doing this plot you're doing that
plot you're doing a third plot then
you're showing them all together with
show yes if there's no data there that's
fine you have an empty plot but if
there's data there but it I see what
you're saying I see what you're saying
you're saying okay so look okay first
question is should there be a visual
indication we've agreed that in certain
cases like a ray plot there is a visual
indication of missing data right okay so
this case of Lists plot where the data
has no home it has no place we don't
know where to put it right do we give a
visual indication of missing data in the
case where there is no place to put the
data right that's really the question if
we did have a good way to do that then I
mean the most obvious way to do it the
most obvious visual way to do it with
some kind of carrot if that's our
indication of something missing
where I don't know well no no I mean
where is it our indication of something
is missing oh oh oh I see missing
argument sort of thing gotcha yep okay
so so here's a related question you know
is there a difference in the behavior
between your list plot of ABC and list
plot of an empty list yes this plot an
empty list is not an error
there's nothing to be plotted there's
nothing wrong with it okay so it's only
in the case where there is content you
know theoretically none of it was usable
right or even some of it wasn't usable I
mean so so here's a possibility okay so
let's look back at our list here we've
got okay
so in this case something defines the
space the value isn't there we
understand how to deal with that that's
just a missing style right use missing
style default is something pink probably
and I think the brick red should be
changed to pink for but we can talk to a
design about it right okay
something else defines but what should
be rendered is missing okay so all of
these cases
that could have a mark of some kind and
probably should have I mean it's more
informative to market than not to right
so what if that had
a pink dot
was a pink tick or dot
so for example in the case of bar chart
right since we know the x-coordinate but
we just don't know the height well we
have to we have to design a thing in
each case but I mean in the case of this
list plot we know the x-coordinate we
don't know the height so we could have a
pink tick on the X coat on the x-axis
right or we could have like a little
stalk sticking up from the x-axis
stork a you know a stem a little little
piece of stop stock stock I can't do the
American um stock doesn't work those
four names um okay I mean I think it's
an interesting idea because I mean look
if we had a missing style automatic that
did all this pink re and a missing style
none that just doesn't plot on a thing
as that would be at least easy to
understand right
okay so in the case there's no
predefined space to put in a thing there
what we would do is a you know a pink a
pink tick
you know in the in the gap
extra pipe pie slice should have been
that would be probably the thing to do
you
so in a case like this what would it do
in a case like this what you would see
is you would see a little pink things
down here
right a pink arrow or a carrot type
thing down here is it happy pretty nice
actually quite nice I think and you know
is it objectionable well if you don't
like it
clean out the missing data no turn off
the style yeah right okay so in the case
where there's nothing to plot what do we
do in the case where there's nothing to
plot okay in the case where it's
completely homeless
where do the carrots go see what I'm
saying
I mean we should ask Jeremy he might
have a good idea but I'm thinking maybe
there's a pink circle somewhere on the
plot I mean it would almost have to be
at the origin I think no why
I mean what if the origin isn't there I
was thinking it's often the bottom right
hand corner or something more like a
legend II position I mean the problem is
what I could imagine it doing that's a
little bizarre is a is a pool like a
pink circular region with a bunch of red
carrots inside it see what I'm saying so
that's indicating there this number of
points that are homeless in this plot
I mean I think it's more useful to give
you know honestly it's it's definitively
more useful to give a visual indication
of missing data than to just split out
error messages do we agree about that
not necessarily I mean I think the
visual indicators you know some of them
make sense and some of them it feels
like we're stretching too much and you'd
be better off you like this list plot at
the end yeah that you're better off just
issuing a message and not trying to draw
anything
maybe mr. Joe you know Allred I know it
feels to be the harshness of usual and
we always feel we made a mistake
somebody made a mistake or didn't do as
well as they could have right on the
live stream the suggestion is why not a
small exclamation mark with a circle
rounded on the top right not obviously
unreasonable but you know the problem is
yeah you would still need like a tooltip
to just you know explain what is going
on right so look the two choices are
okay
the okay there's two issues partial
homelessness so to speak and total so to
speak net in other words there are some
homeless points and all points are
homeless and if there are if it's
partial then what do we do
okay so there's there's okay so two
cases I don't think there should be a
miss edge if it's partial okay good it's
pretty close
you extract some data from that I said
you want to plot there some missing yeah
it's all really a mistake no I agree I
mean the case where there are no points
is usually a case where you just didn't
process the data correctly and it's the
wrong shape I mean that's the most
common situation right you just screwed
something up completely yes and it would
be useful to see what the points
actually look like
we have another question on livestream
about Wolfram powered API for writing
and deploying smart contracts on
distributed Ledger's that the problem
with these meetings is these are working
meetings so it we're trying to stay
focused on whatever topic we're we're
discussing and actually the meeting that
I am late for is about something very
closely related to the the actual topic
that you just asked about but um and I
need to get going to that I mean I think
in the meantime we can start to
for structure yeah well some things here
are really quite clear some of them are
clear and some of them you know we can
put in you know the data collection
internally to know you know how many in
which things were considered missing or
and then come back and figure out what
we're actually going to do with that
info yeah
I mean I'm still wondering I'm wondering
about this the case etienne you are
arguing there shouldn't be a message
when there's partial placeless things
right but maybe you'd like to know how
many place list things there are or that
there are place listing than that plot
yeah so in that case actually the viewer
suggestion of putting sums is Commission
point somewhere and then if you mouse
over the exclamation you have a
indication five data points were missing
that could be a good of an information
little information icon somewhere well
actually what we do in most malphur is
we simply say five missing points yeah
but this would say in a message and
again no no no I mean we could we could
write it on the plot if we wanted to I
mean we could put an actual indication
on what look we could write on the plot
five missing the problem with that is
it's in English you might not want that
in English it's a there's a whole
complicated story there I mean the other
possibility is some iconic thing I'm
still a believer in the in the vertical
in the carrot as an indicator of
something missing well okay here's
another possibility which would be more
work and still doesn't necessarily solve
the advertisement problem that there was
something missing which is that if the
graphics had you know an attached cell
similar to images and whatnot that's a
piece of information that could go into
there in some form you know what I've
got a better idea why don't we put a red
dotted line around this thing that can
be
and what would happen when we explored
the plot because probably deadlines
entirely or [ __ ] if you selected
entirely to know that this thing was a
you know a plot where something was
wrong I mean I I don't know whether okay
so okay a possibility would be okay well
this is a graphics question um
gesture from me from our very
wonderfully prolific person whose name I
must learn to pronounce SG Heisman but I
don't know whether that's the correct
pronunciation somebody's gonna have to
tell me the correct pronunciation that's
one thing we don't get from these live
streams
I admit that that looks pretty nice I
mean it hopes that there's no points
right underneath it
yes I probably should be outside the
project as well really put it outside
the plot then you mess up the framing
the alignment of plots with each other
that is nice I mean honestly you know
one of the things that I think we have
to if I were if we were to do this it
might not look quite as woops
that's fell okay actually that's even
better perhaps point well okay it's
change five to fifty you know in the
first one and without the one over
you
it's not horrible I mean you know one
could look but there's ways to deal with
that issue
I'm right
you
and then there will be releasing data
whatever option to remove that I was
yeah but I mean so what that's doing I
have to admit this looks a lot nicer
than I expected it to and in the case
where there's absolutely nothing in the
plot it definitely gives an indication
that there was something wrong
I mean the problem is you know could be
a triangle as well as a warning yeah I
don't know whether that whether that
aspect of the iconography is quite right
but um this is interesting it's
interesting I think in this case I'd
almost prefer to attach it to you know
as a frame tic or something or a frame
label
you know something small but still
outside the scene like this hey how do
my question about how to him okay we got
we got the answer here yeah okay there
we go
for how's it same name okay thank you
sander the UM so Santa has another
suggestion here perhaps not a circle the
disc with white background yeah I agree
I mean that's that's the obvious thing
to do for this case um that will
certainly I mean actually probably the
right thing to do is to have an opacity
if we did that where we have this maybe
that's crazy
opacity 0.5 if I'm doing this correctly
so I did point six white then was that
going to do the right thing
ah stupid wrong you just need the edge
form then edge former Fred yeah what I
was trying to do there anyways yeah but
doesn't really matter but I was trying
to I was trying to uh you know it's
basically gray down the point that
overlap rate you're trying to add a
scrim yes correct
and sander here has a um triangle which
as he says looks considerably harsher I
think a circle is much more benign
um I mean arguably um right well this is
very useful okay um I think I need to go
to my next meeting
but let's let's plan on picking this up
again within a couple of weeks let's say
and try and talk about some of think I
think you will have found other cases by
then um I think we haven't discussed
properly missing in the case of
computations um and that's a separate
thing to do I mean I haven't a clue what
we do with missing and dendrograms and
things like that I wouldn't even guess I
mean actually I'm just gonna show one
more case of missing that's interesting
okay it's not quite missing but if I do
slider of one point to does that
you know that's an interesting model for
what to do in these plots and that's
that that supports my idea of these
these little texts and things you know
red ticks that gives us a model for
thinking about those
so I think well with what we're coming
to is if it's homeless use a sand or a
circle so to speak if it's um if it
isn't if there is a if it has at least
one coordinate okay if it has all of its
coordinates then it's going to use a
pink and it's gonna fill with pink to
indicate that we don't know what the
value is right if it has all its
coordinates like in a Geo region value
plots right if it's if it has one of its
coordinates then we give it a carat on
that axis on the axis of the known
coordinate now in 3d that's a little
more complicated we would have to put
carrots on the base we have to see what
that looks like to put some kind of
little carrot II Coney things on the
base
all right much as I'd like to continue
here I've got to go take on something
completely different that's also very
interesting but just different topic
okay all right bye see you later see you
later bye bye thanks live stream people